Hey, what's going on as bill burn?
It's time for the Thursday afternoon.
Just before Friday. Monday
morning podcast in, ah,
just checking in on you.
[inaudible] how are Ya?
What's going on? Jesus Christ.
I wrote my little notes here. I will
collect, collect ticks instead of Celtics.
Huh? Oh fuck. There's another helicopter
flying over. I am out here in Los Angeles.
Los Angeles is on fire.
Um,
that's all everybody's talking
about. Oh my God. Are you okay?
How are you anywhere near the fire.
I am fine.
I am fine. I have not had
to evacuate yet. I have a,
I've driven past the fires. It's
just, it's just what happens out here.
Plus a global warming is the issue.
Earlier this year we had unseasonably
high rains in the hills, turn green.
It looked like fucking Portland,
Oregon and the fucking dumb ass may
or out his leg. The drought is over.
Everybody goes back to water and they're
fucking lines and it's just like the
drought is never over out here.
It's over fucking populated and we live
in a place that should not exist. Okay.
That is such a fucking
irresponsible statement.
We have enough water now
where there isn't a drought,
but please conserve it because we don't
know when it's gonna rain like that
again. Thank you. And it's, you know,
it's on to Chicago and let's win there.
That's what the fuck she should have said.
Oh Hey, I know where the fuck it was.
Right?
So all it did was just fatten up the
fucking lands that always burned out here.
Anyways, so Santa and Wednesday come
in after my Javvi desert over there.
It's like a giant fucking hair dry.
It dries out the fucking they'll fuck
in the hills in it. Lights on fire.
The problem is people live there now.
So then that's when it becomes a problem.
Mike, oh, are you going?
How are they gonna get their
fucking Prius out of there?
Um, by the way, I love all
the people playing like
politics, you know, going good.
All those fucking liberals
are burning out there. It's a,
La is one of the most conservative fucking
places you're ever going to live in.
The second she get into the valley,
just get out of there.
Get out of Hollywood with all these
starlets solving problems as they accept a
fucking award.
You know,
let's not forget about the fucking planet
poses in the cove next to the blood
diamonds. Thank you so much. This
one's for all the fat bitches, right?
Whatever the fuck it
is. They say, you know,
before they jump in their limo back to
the fucking gated community outside,
outside, you just go to Burbank
and they're making it great again.
All right.
And first of all,
what kind of a fucking ass watch his
fellow Americans houses burned down,
you know, and they actually are
happy about it. You know what I mean?
This is how fucked up like,
like politics has become in this,
in this goddamn country. However,
I feel like Hollywood did
bring it on themselves with
their fucking finger wagon.
You know, I told you that fucking jerk
off. So this guy on Twitter and he goes,
okay, in case you didn't take your
smart pills today, um, Obama is awesome.
It's just like, look, how dumb are you
that that's how you'd present your point.
As opposed to me who just
calls everybody comes,
he should do it the way that
I do it. So anyways, I'm
watching all of this shit happen
and knowing that, you know,
and I believe anyways that we are
playing a major role in it is really
depressing. But I've, I've now I've got
myself in a positive mindset about it.
I just think they, they, they're going
to look at like the last hundred years
is just this, um, period in our
history where we were wrong.
I mean,
it's not wrong with oil.
We didn't fucking realize that it
was going to do all of this shit.
But now we know and I think
there's getting in the future,
I think that we're going to, hopefully
we'll utilize solar power, wind,
uh, water or whatever the fuck it is at
these egg heads know how to use, I mean,
I show you, I saw that flash
like the other day. It just
runs on water. I mean, we,
we can do stuff like this and
we can live happily. All right.
We don't need to cut beaks off chickens.
You know,
I think in every period, like when you
look at how we get to live right now,
it's fucking amazing.
And even still how we treat each other
is amazing compared to way we did it for
500 years ago.
Well,
eventually there's going to be four or
500 years beyond this and they're going
to be looking at us like
they were barbarians and
they were spraying on leaded
fuel until the address. Fear was
hating. God, policies were burning down.
They bought the big stuff that
chickens. Right. You know,
as we sit there thinking we're fucking
amazing because we can take a pill that
makes her dick stand up
even though we're 85. Um,
so I think we're going to
come out of it. I think, uh,
what has to happen is to solar people
have to start paying off politicians the
way the oil people do.
And once that happens,
then hopefully what will happen is the
same thing that happened in my business
where I watched everybody being at
the big three networks all of a sudden
wanting to be over at Netflix.
So if you look at the big three,
like NBC, ABC, and CBS is,
you know, the oil companies,
hopefully everybody will jump
over to like solar stuff.
And I know what people are saying. They,
well, you know, you need fucking January,
January, she boogie [inaudible]
I know, I realize that.
I realize that there's always going
to be some sort of lubricant. Um,
I understand that. But you
know, have you seen that, that,
that fucking shit that Tesla guy came out
with where they got the, they got the,
uh, the roof tiles that are solar.
I don't know if they work yet.
I don't know if he can even fucking get
it. But if those things fucking work,
and I mean there's a thing,
there's a thing that below
$1 billion a month on,
right as a plos post,
a fly and [inaudible] trying to find
fucking people with the little bag of
dynamite and some nails in it.
Those little cock suckers over there,
man, they fucking bankrupt in us
running around with a little trick or
treat bag and we'll fucking see sitting in
$1 billion worth of shit
at him every fucking month.
They're never going to
defeat us in that game.
They're going to kill this
fucking financially. That's it.
I'm off my tree stump
that just burned down.
One of the great things about spending a
lot of time alone is nobody debates the
points you're making.
So you always feel like you're right.
And that's what I'm doing right
now. Um, please by all means,
don't take any of this shit seriously.
Alright? I'm just fucking around.
I talk about what's in the news.
Okay? Don't get your red tie.
Oh, your blue tie or your
fucking panties in a bunch.
Alright.
Grow the fuck up.
Um,
hey, what's going on this
weekend? Not The fucking La Rams.
The who would have thought La fucking
rams. What are they? 92, 10 and two.
I don't know where the fuck we are.
I'm too busy editing.
The third season of F is for family.
Um, I don't know where the hell we are.
God dammit.
It's already December.
Can you believe that the regular
season of football is almost over?
The regular season of college
football is already over.
We're already into the bowl season.
It's just unfucking believable how fast
the football season goes by September,
October, November, December.
If you look at baseball,
that's April, May, June, July.
Well, no wonder they still play September.
We've also, they still play September,
August, September and into October and
into fucking November. Oh, there you go.
Unfucking believable. Um, well I guess
they play into February here, right?
Who knows. Anyways, um, I was actually
going to have time next week to,
uh, start flying again. The helicopter.
I was going to try and get up to
150 hours by the end of the year.
And I had this flight I wanted to do
from long beach up to Bakersfield over to
Santa Barbara and then back down to a
long beach and was going gonna take me
roughly like three hours.
And I was going to do that about five,
six times and I was
going to get my, uh, um,
I was going to be up to 150 hours and uh,
then the fire's games and I was
like, all right, you know what,
I'm not going to be another asshole
up there in the fucking way.
And plus I don't want to have to deal with
trying to fly around that shit. So, uh,
I don't know, maybe I'll do it in January
cause I'm taking most of January off.
Um, by the way, I was going to be in Santa
Barbara this weekend. That got moved. Um,
that got cancelled and moved
because of the fires. Um,
so I don't know,
maybe in February or something like that.
I'll let you guys know what the
a three sheds you'll date is. Um,
anyways, let's, uh, let's move ahead.
Um,
oh,
and also I forgot to trash the liberals
that we're happy that Rupert Murdoch's
house caught on fire too. I mean, do you
just, you just beyond a childish cunt,
if watching another person's house on
fire because you don't agree with their
fucking political, but views, it's just,
that just blows my mind,
you know,
I don't know. Look, if it's Thai caught
on fire anymore, blah, blah, blah. Well,
when he had to pat it off, cause
I mean, that's funny. You know,
the guy's got a zillion fucking ties.
He probably has a zillion houses too.
I mean, what, what am I saying
here? I'll tell you what I'm saying.
I watched the Celtics, I'm getting
caught up on the sellies, the Celtics.
I watched my Bruins,
uh,
make a valiant effort to get
back in the game with Nashville,
which they did a bright, as I said,
in the second period, I was just like,
just come on man.
Let's go one fucking goal here
before the end of the second period.
They did still ended up
losing a five to three,
but, um, I dunno, I dunno what
the Bruins are doing, you know,
I was like,
what the fuck are they doing when they
blew up the team and then we started to
make some progress last year and this
year I know what I think we just have,
we had a bunch of injuries and shit,
so I'm still holding out hope that they
know what they're doing. But I just,
I think we just signed some guy that
was more of a physical presence,
but somebody we're still
feeling the effects of not
having Lou Cheech out there,
man. Every three or four shifts.
But, uh, I watched the Celtics first,
the, uh, the Milwaukee Bucks and I watch
that Yannis, uh, super cal fragile,
whatever his fucking name is. Uh,
the Greek freak. Jesus Christ. Yes.
The difference between him last year
when the Celtics played, and this year,
I mean, that guy was
unbelievable. Yeah. He had every,
every fucking shot you
could possibly have.
The guy's hitting fucking three pointers.
He was dunking on gay.
He was dunking on guys.
He was like 12 feet away from the rim,
and he would just reach his
fucking arm. Just keeps going. Um,
I got to see that guy live that is, uh,
that's, uh, when he's fucking young,
before his knees and they
start, you know, like, you know,
like when you look at Tom Brady and
he was like, what do you see as socks?
And you can see there's all kinds of metal
and shit underneath his fucking socks
now. Um hmm. Or like Allen Iverson,
who by the end was wearing like a catsuit,
you know,
they had like those compression sleeves
and then you got one on your leg. Um,
I want to see that dude when
he's fucking young, you know,
not favored and injury, just dunking on
people the way I saw the other night.
It was, it was, it was an
incredible display. Um,
I got to start watching them. I
just don't have fucking time. I,
this is what I take. I take
Bruins, Celtics, patriots,
and Duke University.
MMM.
And I try to stay up on those
as much as I can. And, um,
I got to start taping the Kansas
Jayhawks too. And there's just,
there's just not enough fucking time.
Kansas Jayhawks that's my first team.
That's my first team. But I got into Duke
last year when I went to that game and,
um,
okay.
I Dunno.
And I also,
I called in this show and I got to talk
to coach k and he was talking about like
how hard it is to recruit now,
uh,
because everybody's like one and done
and he somehow got another whole batch of
one and done or said or the shit.
Two or three guys and a, I dunno,
it's like what Kentucky does every year,
but a, I don't know what happened to me.
I've slowly become like a college sports
fan while trying to still pay attention
to the pro shit. Still not knowing what
the Los Angeles Rams record is. All right.
Well we got, we got, Jared
was hitting golf Joffe,
however the fuck he sits at his,
his last name is like,
how do you say Gif Gif said Gif is it Gif,
um, versus, uh, Carson Wentz. Um,
although I got to tell you after watching
the Seattle Seahawks last fucking week,
I mean that was, that was a, that was an
MVP level performance by Russell Wilson.
I don't know, I couldn't even tell
how good their offensive life.
It was good if it just absolutely sucked.
It was like every fucking play drop back
for a pass. They'd be like three eagles,
you know, defensive lineman in
his face and he would just fucking
zigzag around up dead changed direction.
Do is spin.
The one thing I will say about the
Seahawks offensive line is they are really
good about not holding when some shit
like that because usually when somebody
changes direction somebodies like, oh
fuck, now you're going back the other way.
Then they just, there they can't
fight the urge to just hold.
They were really good about not doing
that shit I guess when you can't really
tackle somebody, there's
no reason to block. But um,
I was really,
really impressed with how well Pete
Carroll had those guys playing in the fact
that,
uh,
Sherman was out with the ruptured
Achilles and you hate to see that.
Where is the fun beating Seattle? If
sh, you know, Sherman isn't playing,
you're not beating the
Seahawks. I mean, come on,
you're beating an injured fucking
team, but they stay still looked. Uh,
I think the Patriots,
Jesus Christ,
we don't get enough
pressure on the quarterback.
Forget about a guy that
runs around like that.
I would not want to play those
guys. Um, there I admitted it.
They were scary fucking team quite.
Let me read a little bit of, um,
let me read a little bit of this shit
here. Um, the advertising. All right,
man crate everybody. This crate
is from mentally. All right lady.
She got your own gyms. Alright,
you making your speeches,
all your feminist speeches.
We'll look what happens now.
There's the pushback man
crate a crate for a mad.
Um, or if you're a lady out there and you
want to get by your guy, create a shit.
This is probably, it's hard to pick.
It's hard to pick out the perfect gift.
It's also hard to fucking
mind for diamonds,
but all too easy to get it totally wrong.
Introducing mad great.com the surest
way to find awesome gifts guys will love
guaranteed a,
this isn't a lane cheese of the month
club or a new tie man crate offers gifts
for every type of guy from the rugged
outdoorsman to this sports fanatic and
everyone in between.
Ah,
the alligator arm that the rugged
outdoorsman to the sports fanatic.
C'Mon man. I, once they
said the rugged outdoorsman,
I thought they're going to
be to the hipster with the
genes that are making them
not be able to have a
fucking baby anymore. Um,
like the whiskey appreciation crate.
Holy Shit. I love these people.
These people have my
full fucking endorsement.
The whiskey appreciation crate,
the fuck is that with a personalized
lasered edge to canter and glasses for his
favorite drink.
They put your name on the glass.
You don't even feel like an alcoholic.
You feel like you accomplished something.
I love man crate and the grill master
crate with a brass knuckle meat tenderizer
and a cast iron smoker box.
Jason's,
that's for the fucking angry guy.
Just go to [inaudible] dot com pick the
perfect crate and choose your delivery
date.
When his man crate arrives,
he'll be the envy of every guy in the
room as he prize that bad boy open with
his own laser engraved crowbar.
Uh,
they have thousands of five star reviews
and every man Craig comes with their
high five guarantee on the holidays.
Go to man,
create.com/burr to get 5% off your order.
They don't offer this
discount anywhere else.
That's 5% off at Man [inaudible] man
crates.com/pro was I saying wrong? No,
it's man crates.com. Sorry. Plural.
M A N C r a t e
s.com/berg.
Alright. Tipsy elves, everyone.
All right, everyone needs,
and I want to see that
fucking Greek Freak Duncan,
a bunch of tipsy elves hubbub that
everyone needs an ugly Christmas sweater
this time of year.
If you want bragging rights for the most
talked about sweater at your Christmas
party. Listen up a while. You're
shopping for your ugly sweater.
Check out the other holidays,
the all the hall,
other holiday attire for yourself
or as a gift like adult onesies.
They even sell wild and wild and
crazy ski suits for your skiers.
Few skiers out there for men, three P's,
Christmas suits, interactive sweaters,
beer pong, corn hole, and
hilarious holiday tee shirts
for women. Holiday leggings,
whore it up,
sweater dresses and cozy adult onesies,
specific sizing for men.
And so everyone can get a perfect fit.
You know what those adult onesies
remind me of. You know those people,
I don't even believe
that they agree exists.
Those people that dress up like mascots
so they can fuck each other with some
donkey head on. I don't exist. I don't
believe that those people exist. Um,
or is that a stepping
stone just to beastiality
you know,
once you fucking like the Ohio
state Buckeye fucks the A,
I dunno what the San Diego chicken.
That's so fucking weird right now.
My listeners get 20% off tipsy elves.com
when you use my code Burra checkout,
that's 20% off anything you order
on the right on the site shop now.
So you don't have a,
so you have the best selection to choose
from and have it in time for your ugly
Christmas sweater party.
Go to tipsy elves.com enter
my code burr checkout.
Uh
Oh. Enter my code burr at
checkout to get your 20% off.
Sitewide discount.
That's tipsy elves.com and my code bar.
Oh look who's here.
Everybody about who to do beyond these
[inaudible] La is fucking on fire.
Doo Doo Doo Doo. Brds beyond
the summit. Fuck it. Lit a tire.
It rolled into the hills
and burn the houses down.
The guy who created the Ninja turtles
now as address like a clown because
he had all his money in a fucking safe
inside his house at fucking burned down.
The money didn't burn.
The fire department stole it, but
now, but now, but DB boom. Um,
and that's a big thing.
You know,
just like this corrupt
referees in the NBA,
there's corrupt firemen and you'll have,
you'll have a fire in your
fucking garage and then, you know,
they'll put that out. And when
you go into your bedroom, you,
your wife's missing your earrings. Where's
my earrings at? Burned up in the fire.
Me undies,
everybody.
Every year millions of people received
the least light gift of all time
underwear.
Uh,
but we will still give it to our family
and our loved ones who just don't want
it. But maybe it's not that
that the underwears the problem.
Maybe it's the kind of underwear.
Let me tell you about me undies.
The only underwear that makes for an
amazing gift bmds made underwear the
perfect gift that everyone
is going to love you for.
It's a Goddamn holiday miracle
Jack Nicholson should be then.
It's a Goddamn holiday mayor this year.
Don't give underwear.
Give me undies this holiday season to
get your exclusive 20% off the softest
underwear and socks you'll
ever wear. Where, where, where,
where free shipping and 100%
satisfaction guaranteed. Go to me.
He's dot com slash [inaudible] that's
[inaudible] dot com slash bar and the last
one lastly,
but not leastly pro fucking for
pro flowers. Everybody, if there aren't
people, you're going to see this holiday.
Don't send a gift card or the
same old holiday traditional shit.
Send a pro flowers bouquet
or plant through it.
If you're a guy,
you should send one of these to another
guy friend just cause it's fucking
hilarious. You know, thinking of
you with like hugs and kisses,
their bestselling candy cane roses
are a great option for a holiday gift.
I'm going to send that to Joe de Rosa
candy cane roses and you know what?
He'd hold fucking love it.
December birthday or anniversary.
Or you can always go with their classic
mini Christmas tree that comes with
lights and ornaments. I'm going to get
one of those because we're going back.
We're going back to you. Did she go
family bed gauged uh, for Christmas.
So, uh, maybe I'll get one
of those. He can't lose,
no matter which bouquet you send. My
listeners get 20% off any of pro flowers,
unique bouquets of $29 or
more pro flower bouquets.
And plants are guaranteed to stay fresh
and you control the delivery date.
Set it and forget it. Pro Flowers
gives you more bloom for your buck.
Big beautiful flowers.
More stems for your money and
long lasting freshness. Uh,
to get 20% off all bouquets of $29.
A more.
Go to pro flowers.com and use
my code [inaudible] at checkout.
That's pro flowers.com and code bar.
All right.
Guess what I'm doing? Um,
this this fucking month.
I am trying to stay off social
media because I think it is a,
uh, I think it has, it's, it's,
it definitely has its good points.
All right? But wherever they
are, I don't see them right now.
I'm taking a month off.
I'll still obviously tweet and post shit,
but I'm not reading anything
or any of that fucking crap.
Um, I'm trying to be
perfect Billy, this month.
I'm trying to go back to the bill
that I was when I was eight years old.
I didn't drink. You know, I didn't
take the occasional hit a weed.
I didn't fucking, I
didn't watch porno. Right?
I didn't watch people getting fucking
slapped by gorillas on fucking youtube,
but didn't exist.
Okay.
I ended up pure fucking mind.
I went outside,
I picked up a stick and I played cowboys
and Indians and reenacted the genocide
that made this country. What
it is. Okay. I was innocent.
Uh, yeah. I'm just trying to fucking, I'm
trying to slow it down here. All right.
I've been doing great man.
Uh,
d del Rey has gotten me on this
fucking diet that is working for me.
I just got to eat more
salads. I gotta get, I get,
I haven't been doing that lately,
but, uh, um, I swear to God.
I know you guys are
going to fucking hate me.
I know you're going to fucking hate me.
I'm laying off the bread.
I'm kind of doing that gluten free thing,
you know? And I used to always be like,
fuck that dude. I'm always eating
pizza. I'm always eaten bread and shit.
I got to tell you something dude.
The fucking waitress,
if you don't booze and you lay off the
bread and the flower that and you eat
well that the fit,
the Fed has no way to hide.
It's like fucking roaches when you
turn the light or I guess they run an,
I don't think, I don't know what it is.
I don't know. I don't know what the,
I don't know. Hey people, I don't know
what the fucking analogy is. It's,
it's out there somewhere.
All right. But it's not
in my brain right now. Um,
and I'm actually liking the Goddamn food.
I finally went to steel cut oats.
Uh,
and for some reason on this diet,
I'm putting a little brown sugar
and a little bit of butter in there.
It's been fucking tremendous.
And I know there's all these
people and I don't like that.
Glad is going to clog up your
arteries. You know what? Fuck you,
I got to eat something.
MMM.
Then I have a couple of eggs over AEG.
I,
I got this other thing that I can make
some times of breakfast where it's just
keen what black beans in an egg. I throw
a little salsa on top, fucking delicious.
I just don't wrap it up. One of those
giant flour tortillas, you know,
with the fucking,
you know what the deal is.
Then all of a sudden you start throwing
the sour cream on and the cheese and all
of that shit and you
literally like you fucking,
you leave the Taco stand and you fucking
walking out like lean into one side,
like someone punched in your fucking ribs.
Um, yeah. And then also I,
uh,
my teeth will get fucked up down
the bottom. Just as you get older,
I guess your job keeps
growing or whatever.
This is whatever the fucking
dentist told me. So I actually,
I finally bit the bullet and
I got that fucking Invisalign,
so I got to wear that thing for the
next 12 to 16 weeks and I'll do it.
I'll tell you right now,
dude, it fucking sucks.
It sucks man.
But it definitely makes you
eat less because it's like,
I don't want to take this fucking thing
out and go through this whole rig of
Morel.
MMM.
Oh my God, Dude. You realize I'm bald.
I'm going to be 50 and be wearing braces.
Can you want us,
do you understand the Trifecta of fucking
thank God I have knee and my life.
Can you mind if I was a single man
and that's what the fuck I was doing.
Okay.
Um, I'm kind of doing like a fucking
light overhaul on my body right now.
I'm laying off the booze.
I'm getting my fucking teeth down the
bottom because I was starting to look like
a fucking,
I dunno what some sort of a,
where are my references today?
I don't know why the hell they are.
I'm trying to think that there's
a couple of fucking wild.
Yeah.
What's dead fucking thing that exists in
mmm,
South American. It's the worst kind
of animal to be. It's like you would,
you're like,
you exist to keep the top predators alive.
Like people are, they fuck like rabbits.
The reason why rabbits fuck like that.
And they have all this because
everybody eats them in the wild. Okay.
They'll let their like the, the, hey,
you guys want to get some sliders.
That's where like rabbits are in the wild.
So there's some sort of fucking,
it's not a pig and it's not a rat.
What does that fuck?
I gotta look it up now.
South
America.
I want to go to South America.
So bad South American pig rat.
Let's see what they show it. The
fuck is it? Come on man. Come on.
Internet.
Yeah.
A cabby cabby Barra. Is that what
it is? These giant Guinea pigs.
That's what my lower teeth
are starting to look like.
Come on clicking on the images.
Did I do it right?
Did I fucking nailed it?
Fucking nailed it.
It's like if a squirrel fucked up pig.
Well they have,
they have like surprisingly
one of the pig size rats.
I got to omit the kind of cute, the
face really makes them fucking cute. Um,
this is going to be like the next
Pixar movie. These giant motherfuckers.
Um,
okay.
By the way, Dude. Yeah. I
have South American man. I've,
I've wanted to go there for so God
damn long. I just don't have the time.
I'd love to go down there and
do a fucking show, you know,
I've always wanted to go to the
Galapagos Islands. All of this shit.
It just seems green and
beautiful. You know, I don't know.
I gotta get my ass fucking down there at
some point. Why? Why the hell wouldn't I?
If I talk about global warming,
why don't I jump on a fucking jet plane
and spray on leaded leaded fuel across
the fucking atmosphere for a
good 12 hour flight from La.
This is how dumb I am. I actually thought,
cause I moved out here, I was actually,
it's a shorter flight to fucking
like Brazil or something.
I didn't realize that like,
you know when you look at it,
if you were in New York and he flew
due south, you'd be on the east,
the west coast of their country. Um,
yeah. Bill. Yeah, we all have a globe.
We've all looked at a map at some point.
Well you know what,
sometimes I don't look at Shit.
Um,
anyways, so I don't know shit
about NFL football this year.
So I'm actually gonna go out on a limb
here and say something that is based on
watching one football game.
Um,
I'm actually thinking all right that
the winner of the Rams Eagles game will
fucking lose to Seattle or the
Seattle might be on the road,
can play off time. I have no,
can you imagine if Marshawn
lynch didn't fuck them,
retire and kept, was still playing
with them, but they got that other kid,
that fucking mini Marshawn that
came with a fucking maniac.
Like I don't know what p care, what
the Fuck Pete Carol does, you know,
aside from looking the other way,
would half his defense is doing fucking
steroids? I don't know what they are.
What's in the water up there in Seattle,
but they got some people that
could fucking play. Um, all right,
I'm done blowing the Seattle
Seahawks. Um, all right,
that's the podcast here for this,
uh,
this wonderful Thursday,
um,
all sober bill who would have
thought all slender sober bill.
I finally stood on the scale
today up to fucking not booze and
eating like a fucking Hollywood douche.
And um,
you know, when I went back in August,
I was pushing like, I was like one 87.
I was pushing like a push and you know,
it's closing in on 200 days.
Um,
I'm now down to about,
I said one 71.6.
It's perfect.
My clothes fit now and this is what
I'm going to do this time. All right.
I'm actually going to buy jeans that fit,
you know,
when I'm this weight because the
problem is, is I have a bump.
All my jeans fit me when I'm one 87 so
as I put on the way, and I don't notice,
I'm all comfortable, I just fucking
walking around my big fucking Jade's Oh,
Billy big jeans.
Oh,
that might be my favorite
one. Oh, Billy big jeans.
I'm not fucking doing it anymore.
Do you understand me?
These still speak English of fucking Bob.
I'm gonna uh,
does like a skid row right
down the street from me.
I don't go to goodwill anymore. I
don't trust those cuts. All right?
What I do is I go down
to skid row and I got,
Hey, you homeless mother
fuckers want free clothes?
Um, no, I don't do that. I s you know,
anybody who is sort of
my size step right up.
I just know I go down and I just have the
bag and I walk up to where their tents
are and I just fucking set it down and
I turned around and I walk away like
fucking Santa Claus for junkies.
Okay. And I got all kinds
of shit in there, you know?
And it's just funny to me that uh,
that I'm,
I'm giving away clothes that like,
maybe I like this,
some like fucking homeless guy walking
around wearing a shirt that I wore on
Conan O'brien.
I know what I should be doing is going
down there and thinking, oh my God,
this is so sad that fellow
Americans have to live this way.
But I am such a self
involved Hollywood douche.
I actually walk away still thinking about
how about myself and how I just gave
away close that had TV credits.
You know,
I hate that about myself, but you
know, I'm just being honest. I do.
And I also feel good that I
did something like that. Right?
It's all that stuff that allegedly
Jesus doesn't appreciate, you know,
he then spraying in public,
I should just do that shit.
And not tell you guys that I did it,
but now I'm telling you that I did it.
Which takes away the,
uh,
the good deed because
if you do a good deed,
just so you can walk
around and talk about her,
sit down and talk about it on a podcast,
you're not a good person.
You're a cunt and a, yeah, so
that's what we learned here.
You know,
if there really was a Jesus,
if there really was a Santa Claus did
be coal in my stocking and I would be on
my way to the fiery depths of health,
right?
According to my religion, just because I
went down there and I gave the clothes,
but then told you guys about it.
That's how it works in my religion.
That's how my religion is.
I'm all right.
I don't even know what the fuck I'm
talking about this point. All right.
That's the end of the podcast.
Okay.
But fortunately we have
some bonus material for you.
We're going to play a little music.
The Great Andrew Feminists always
comes up with these tracks.
You guys are always out gay man.
Like, who is this being? Well, Bill,
you listen to all this interesting music.
It's not me. It's Andrew. All right.
And then after the music is over,
you'll then be able to listen to a,
a greatest hits podcast from a Thursday
gone by from earlier this year of
fucking, I don't know, whenever the hell
I started these and that's how it works.
And if you have a problem with that,
then you know what I would do?
I would go to the all things comedy
network and I will listen to a different
podcast.
By the way,
thank you guys so much for buying tickets
to the Patrice O'neil comedy benefit.
Um,
tickets are going fast.
The lower level is already sold out.
Now we've got the upper two decks to go.
You know what?
It makes a wonderful Christmas gift.
Why don't you get your best guy, friend
a fucking, um, uh,
uh,
Kay of candy cane fucking
roses from pro flowers and get,
you know,
and then in the card when they think that,
that you went gay for them and
they're going like, oh my God,
how do I still hang out with this guy?
I thought it wasn't homophobic.
I'm not homophobic until my best guy
friend who I thought was straight has a
crush on me.
Is that considered homophobia?
Okay. If you don't have a
problem with gay people,
but then one of your friends
who you thought was straight,
then I'm going to use this.
The stupid expression becomes gay,
you know, like, like, like, like they
caught the mumps or something. Um,
tells you that this whole time that Ben
gay and that they also have feelings for
you if you get weirded out by that. Like,
dude, I can't hang out with you for,
can I hang out with you for awhile
until, uh, I can't hang out.
I don't think I can hang out with you.
I mean, a woman would say that, right?
If you will. Just like, you know,
I though we'd been friends for awhile,
but I just want to let you know that
I've developed feelings for you. Yeah.
You're not coming over her apartment
to fucking watch survivor at that point
anymore unless, unless she has feelings
for you. Right. Isn't that how it works?
What is it? I don't know. All right.
There's a lot of times I
should have stopped a podcast
10 15 minutes earlier and
uh, this might be one of
those times, I have no idea.
But you don't want to have to do the
second eye fucking shut this off is I have
to put my fucking Invisalign back in.
It's fine once they're fucking in there,
but when you're, when you pop them
in there, like it's, you know,
to get the
best results were at 22 hours a day.
You know,
you ever go to the airport and you see
those people who like broke their fucking
ankle and then it's like they
got that thing that they are,
it's like a scooter and they can just
rest their knee on it. This is like,
this is the teeth version of that.
I don't understand why those people
just don't use fucking crunches.
Do they have like that
little upper body strength?
Is their cast that fucking heavy
or is it just more efficient?
Those are the hard hitting questions
we ask here in the podcast. All right,
have a great weekend.
You're constant joy.
The music and the greatest hits Thursday
afternoon, just before Monday. No,
just pull the whole Friday.
Monday morning. Paul.
Yay.
[inaudible]
I have the urge to make
a pumpkin pie this week.
I want to practice before the
holidays. Uh, ginger, scumbag
bill. I've been a fan of
yours for 15 years. Okay,
so you guys got that. This guy has
been a fan of mine for 15 years,
so for 15 years this guy has been falling
me enjoying things that I'm doing.
All right?
This guy's locked in for 15 years.
The people that work hard every day
and spend their hard earned cash.
That's kind of redundant, sir. If you
work hard, then you have harder and cash.
All right? We've got
an easy job, you know,
and then you be spending your
fucking teddy money, right?
They'll just read the fucking email.
All right. Just having fun. Bill,
I've been a fan of yours for 15 years.
The people that work hard every day and
spend their hard earned cash to see you
have been really disappointed.
This is one of the classic things.
When people complain, rather than
just complaining for themselves,
they act like they're standing in front
of like a zillion people and they go,
relax,
attention everyone.
I will send the email and we'll
convey all of your feelings.
Get on with your day.
Relax. I will handle it.
So evidently he has like, you know, all
of these people are disappointed in me.
He said, the people that follow
you and made you who you are,
they made me people.
I didn't work hard on stand up.
I was just standing there
and they all said, hey yo,
we have decided to make you
and who you are. So sad.
It'd be said, so set it be done. He said,
you have made dates all around the
country and then cancelled them.
When Hollywood calls you to do a part,
that's exactly what happened.
I picked up the phone. I said hello.
They said, this is Hollywood here.
We're calling you to do a part c.
Uh,
the people that go to
your shows and made you,
that made you aren't making a
10th of the money that you make,
but they paid to see you. Hey, ginger boy.
Without these fans, you're illiterate. Ass
would be working at Mcdonald's at best.
Now, I take offense to that, sir. Okay?
Without my fan base, I would not be
working at Mcdonald's. You son of a bitch,
I would be unloading trucks in
a warehouse. Get it straight.
He goes, you're a scumbag. Be a gee,
you're a scumbag page and I hope every
fan realizes what you are and stops going
to your shows.
I will never listen to your shows or
podcasts again and we'll tell everyone to
do the same.
You are the typical sellout to
Hollywood fucking disappointment.
I know you won't have the balls to
read this on your podcast. Instead,
you will read a letter from a 20 year old
guy confused about his girlfriend sex,
sexuality.
This is the best part here.
You're a real cunt.
Fuck you and everything you do
as one of the greatest endings where
the greatest sending standing email ever
got your a real cunt. You're
the real deal. If you, if
you tip over your current,
you see the stamp of approval from the
current factory and then it's just not,
fuck you.
It's fuck you in everything you do.
You want to go to the grocery
store? Yeah. That too.
Fuck you when you're picking out apples.
MMM.
Jesus Christ,
sir.
Okay.
You made me,
did I have anything to do?
Did I do anything that I worked?
Did I not fucking go onstage and eat
my balls? Learning how to do this?
I guess you did. I listen. I just
want to thank you for making me,
uh, without your hard work of going
through. I mean, I can't imagine how many,
uh, I mean, how many people
live in this country?
I just can't imagine when you're
just going through the mug book,
trying to figure out who you've decided
will become a professional comedian.
That just is.
And the fact that you also have a day
job during the time where I guess you're
grossly underpaid. I mean, that's
just incredible to me, sir.
What the fuck do you want from me?
Let me ask you this,
okay? If Hollywood called you
and asked you to be in a movie,
you're going to say,
you're going to say no.
All right. And like you told your
mom, Hey, listen Ma, don't worry.
I'll come over and I'll clean up
your yard this Saturday. All right?
And then all of a sudden Hollywood
comes to Collins says, Hey,
do you want to pretend you're
a lot tougher than you are
and get into a gunfight
and gets shot by, I don't know,
whoever your favorite actor is,
you're going to say, no, I have
to go. Uh, I got a stick. What?
You've never broken a fucking,
you know what? Fuck that.
Even like a play off game comes along.
You've never fucking had to change a
schedule, sir. I had to cancel some dates.
I didn't cancel them. I rescheduled
the fuck. Do you want from me?
You want me to stay in the strip malls
for my entire career telling jokes I did
that. I'm trying to fucking,
you know, and all, all,
all these movies to do is make
more people know who I am.
So more people come out to my shows so
I can keep writing more hours and having
a good time. All right. I don't
even know why I'm talking to you.
You said you're never going to
listen to my shit again, right?
Are you a man of your word after you
saying, I'm not a man of my word.
If you're actually listened to this, then
you're a fucking hypocrite. All right.
What's the matter?
Huh?
Jesus Christ.
You fucking pissed on your
sweatpants this weekend.
I don't know what the fuck that was all
about and you didn't even say what it
was.
You may dates all around the country and
then cancelled them with the fuck are
you talking about?
I had one tour.
I had to move around and I fucking
did the first two dates. Then I'm,
I've made up a one to 3 cents then and
add in another one that wasn't even on
that original tour. So go
fuck yourself. All right.
All the tickets are honored and if he
can't make that date, you get it refunded
Jesus Christ. Do you know that
Ted tour that I was going to do?
I was just going to land in Boise,
you know,
jump on a bus and knock them all out in
10 days now because of that whole thing
blew up. Now I've got to get on it, you
know, second extra 10 airplane ride.
You don't hear me bitching,
do you fucking cunt.
You're a real cop. Fuck you and
everything you do that was worth it.
That was worth them getting mad. That's
fucking tremendous, sir. You know what?
As much as you do, you disappointed
me. You're a real disappointment.
You fucking jerk off.
You've liked me for 15 years.
One canceled fucking Gig and now you,
now you're saying fuck me in everything
I do. I make that Pumpkin pie this week.
You saying fuck the pie too. That's a
part of it. You're saying, fuck America.
If you're saying fuck punk Pumpkin Pie.
Yeah,
but I got here, I am a real cunt.
I, you know, I can't argue that.
Okay.
You know something. Could somebody please
put that on a tee shirt? You're a cut.
Fuck
you in everything you do.
Just to have that just out
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible]
we still go onto the regional try gain
is wrong or she'll try it on the seat and
oceans.
We shall fight with growing confidence
and growing strength in the air.
We shall defend our island.
Whatever the cost.
Maybe we shall fight on the beaches or
fight on the landing run and she'll fight
you to the field. I ended up streaks
which will fight in the hills,
which you'll never have.
Surrender.
Pilbara is the Monday morning podcast
and I think I have the swine flu.
Yeah, I'm sweating here. Roasting,
baking, boiling. It's like a fucking
sauna, I guess. Second. Cleveland.
Why did I play Winston
Churchill to begin this podcast?
I'll tell you why you
group of fucking cons.
It's because I'm one week
out from my standup special,
my next hour special that I'm taping
December 17th two shows at the Fillmore in
San Francisco,
California,
and I am beyond fucking ready for this
thing and I'm getting myself psyched up
and I always fucking love that speech
for started as an iron maiden fan.
When power slave came out,
right?
That power slave when the fucking doe,
the live the live,
when they weren't screened for
me, Long Beach. Remember that one?
And they play that speech right
before they went into ace is high.
And I was like, what the fuck is
that speech? That's, you know,
it's incredible.
We had a fight on the land.
We're going fighting this huge in New
York and we shall never saw Landa.
Can you imagine that?
What a fucking time to be alive.
All these fucking NFL coaches getting
credit for their little halftime
adjustments. You, well,
it's win one for the gipper.
There's nothing compared to that shit.
Do you understand what
the fuck was going on?
Can you imagine living in
that little fucking island?
They call it country
over there in England.
That little sissy ass little
fucking island. I'm just
fucking with you. You can't,
you live in over there in England and
you got that fucking sweaty cow licked.
Half a mustache, psychopath,
eight off China, Holland,
getting all those fucking maniacs.
All excited for the blitzkrieg.
Yeah,
and you're sitting there,
haven't yet a little fucking cup of tea.
Whatever the fuck it is you do over there.
You know with your fucking
handmade bridges listening
to the radio or you go to
this guy
shall fight on the land.
We shall fight in this fight in
France. Uh, so fucking greatest.
It's the fucking greatest thing ever.
And they did it.
They fucking fought them off.
They survived the fucking blitzkrieg.
What exactly was the blitzkrieg?
That was a Adolf strategy
where he hits you from the air,
from the sea, and also on the
land all at once was, that's what,
was that what it was or was it
just his bombing? Sort of a,
I don't fucking know. My nose is
clogged up. I want to fucking,
yeah,
I want to know is transplant.
This sucks fucking blows.
I was getting sick all the way to
Cleveland. You know, I fight this shit.
What kind of a fucking asshole gets
a cold in Los Angeles? You know,
that's why I moved out
here. I was like, Oh my God,
I'm so sick of getting this sniffles.
I don't want to get the full
30 for fucking losing my voice.
It's a Sunday night.
It's nine 31 and uh,
just flew back from Cleveland today.
I'm supposed to be in my acting class
and I wasn't able to do that because
obviously, you know, and then one
of those fun, don't you hate that?
Fuck those fucking assholes who are sick
and they still come to work and then,
and then not only do they come to
work, they want to get like, like,
they want you to like be like, wow,
what a trooper. It's like, dude,
you're fucking sick and now you're
gonna make me sick. You know,
get Outta here.
Go crawl back down your fucking man
hole wherever you got that 28 days virus
that you fucking bring in any a, a maniac.
Get outta here. The Fuck Outta here.
What you do here is not important.
Do you understand that?
That's why your cubicle is so small.
Take a fucking day off.
I fucking ain't all those people.
All those assholes.
The first fucking warm day in the
spring and you look out the door,
you see some asshole and a tank top and
fucking short shorts jogging down the
fucking Goddamn River, right?
Right next to the fucking river.
Stupid son of a bitch is going get sick
and then he's going to fucking show up
and get everybody else sick. So I
don't do that shit. When I get sick,
I stay home and I do a podcast.
That's what I do.
Ah, fuck. I got one of those. Those
headaches where if when you're lying down,
it doesn't hurt, and then when you
get up, you almost fucking tip over.
You can feel every time your heart beats
on either side of your forehead. Ah,
fuck. You know what I noticed
is such a weird night. You know,
if you don't watch football like Sunday
night, especially around December,
they showed all the first one episodes.
So they got a lot of reruns and now
they're trying to do some little holiday
special things.
I was just watching Pavarotti duets.
MMM. Live from, I don't know where
I'm going to guess Italy. Uh,
cause it looked European. The guy's
singing an Italian. I know it's opera.
We sing it in anywhere else,
but whatever man,
I turn it on and there's Annie Lennox and
that scraggly dude from the eurythmics
and they're singing some song.
She's a terrible dancer by the way.
I'm really surprised me and he's
standing there stoically and uh,
in a little in his fucking Tuxedo waiting,
waiting to sing.
She's dancing around like a,
you know,
you don't like when you want to
adjust your fucking underwear,
but you can't use your hands
cause you were in public.
So you do that little weird
move with you fucking, you know,
sort of Elvis hole.
You do the WHO [inaudible] my
fucking underwears up my ass.
Right. If I was in Seco, had done
that smoothly, that would have been,
we actually would've been funny.
So anyways,
she's dancing like a fucking retard
and he's just standing there.
She's sitting there going,
sweet dreams are made of these.
Wait for him to be like,
Eh. [inaudible] eh,
but they put up, put up on up or
do I even know what the fuck it is?
I know what they're doing.
You know, I should actually
keep my voice down because,
uh, downstairs is, uh,
this is an old guy who lives beneath
me. Um, just picture of Pat Cooper.
If he wasn't funny,
just keep the rage and eliminate
all the brilliant jokes.
That's what lives underneath me and he's
a fucking cunt. And I'll tell you why,
because he yells at my girlfriend.
All right,
it's fucking old.
Motherfucker yells at my girlfriend,
but he only does it when I'm on the road.
Okay.
Cowardly bastard. So
it's like, first of all,
how the fuck do you know when I'm
not in town? This is what happens.
We have hardwood floors and you know,
my gorgeous girlfriends,
like most gorgeous girlfriends, they
have a lot of Horry shoes. You know,
all women have that little horse shoes.
You know the sound they make
when they go across, you know,
when she tries to put them on the last
seconds before she leaves. You know,
you know that sound of the horseshoes,
the who was shoes hitting the
hardwood floors, maybe some linoleum.
Have any,
you guys notice that you can be engrossed
in the greatest conversation ever with
one of your guy friends. And the second
you hear high heels hitting the floor,
you immediately, both of you stopped
talking. You turned to look, you know,
let's see. Let's see what level
of horror we're talking. Oh, oh,
the old business suit. Oh yeah, I have
a career. I'm not that kind of girl.
You're shoes are giving you a way,
Wendy,
we know all about you and your drunken
escapades down at the Tgi Friday's.
Okay, so stop with your whole
demeanor. More little fucking vibe.
What is going on with that fucking
brought anyways to me more.
And she going to age at any
point. You know what, uh,
when I was flying out back from Cleveland,
I actually sometimes I
don't want to think and I,
I bought people magazine and uh, you
know, you do the crossword puzzle,
you feel smart and uh,
start with seven across on happy days.
Anson Williams.
Oh God, look at that 17 letters. Um,
what am I going, what am I trying
to say here? Yeah. So there's,
so some woman had written in,
um,
I wish I still had the magazine.
Somebody asked me if they were like,
can I look at that? Can you look
at it? You can fucking have it.
Blow your nose on it. I don't
give a shit. People magazine, um,
some lady had written in,
cause they had,
they had written a big article on Demy
Moore where they would just throw stacks,
they throw hard and 48 and then this,
this person had written in and
response to that says sexy.
So hot and 48.
Yeah.
Anybody could be that with
botox at private chef and
a fucking personal trainer.
You know, women are really
competitive with that shit.
You know,
that's like if they did an article and
they talked about the toughest guy I ever
on the planet, you know, no
matter how much you respect them,
at some point you're going to
have to be like, that guy's a fag.
You know though all I would, you know when
I would do right. No, I'm serious dude.
You know I do. I will fucking, I just
walk up to them, you know, like, hey bro,
what's going on? Do you want,
you'll look, I'm going to buy a run.
Which cha the secretary looked away,
dude, I front kick him right in his knee.
Blow out his fucking ACL.
Dude, I'm telling you it works.
I'm taking this fucking Israeli
shit, dude. I'm telling you,
telling you I took like two classes and
now I just use the fucking gears pajamas.
But you know, I still feel like
I know how to fight shut up.
Um,
yeah,
there's a few girls out there who
just are not aging to me more.
And Courtney Cox, I dunno
what to do. Just like,
that's a funny thing about that Courtney
Cox, uh, move, uh, show that she has,
that's out right now where she's a,
you know,
she supposed to be like this desperate,
uh, what the fuck do they call those? Uh,
Jesus wolfs
ducklings.
Cougars. There we go. There we go.
Fucking NYQUIL kicking in baby. Uh, yeah,
she supposed to be this desperate
cougar trying to fucking, you know,
hook up with the younger guy and
it's like, all right. First of all,
she's still hot and she's
in ridiculously good shape.
And then the way they shoot
her with that fucking,
I don't know what the trick is that,
but it basically eliminates
every line in your face.
So now she looks like she's
like 31, 32, you know,
that's a hard age for a woman.
So like [inaudible],
that's the whole fucking thing
doesn't work for me, you know,
and then they got to dress like this,
this,
this is so fucked on that show
because they're trying to appeal,
I guess,
to this certain segment of women that
they're going to watch it who are in that
situation. There's a lot of
divorces out there. 53% right.
But uh,
and the other thing,
but the other side of it is they
have to make her look good. You know,
they got a whore out so they kind of
cancel each other out and like it doesn't
make sense. I'm like
looking at it going, wow,
I fucking bang that girl the
second she's gorgeous. Right.
But then they're making her walk
around like she's desperate.
You know? I just realized, I
admitted that I watched that show.
Where the fuck did I watch it too?
I at least have the out that I
was on the road and I was lonely.
I think I watched that show
by myself in my own apartment.
Wow.
You know,
every once in awhile you find a new
level of sadness in your life that you
didn't even know exist like your existed.
Like just so not even in touch with how
pathetic you're life has become that you
just openly admit something like that.
And then by the end of it, you know,
like if you guys were actually
sitting here like halfway through it,
you would have given me that look the
same look you just gave you fucking iPod
or your radio. Oh, your high fi, whatever
the fuck you listen to this thing on.
You know, cause I, but I didn't see it.
That's the great thing about
this podcast is when I,
when I start opening up and
making an ass out of myself,
you guys can sit there
and laugh at me and fuck,
I wish you were here right now cause
I would have stopped at story. Wow.
That's embarrassing. That is
really fucking embarrassing. Um,
so anyways, I'm sick. Um,
and I'm getting ready to do my special,
but I'm getting over this shit.
I don't give a fuck. I want to thank
everybody came out to see me at hilarity.
He's in Cleveland this past weekend.
I had a great time.
And uh,
you know,
I want to thank nick for having me out
there just to fucking great club owner,
you know, salt of the Earth Guy. He's
one of these guys, he's like fucking,
I don't know how old the guy is.
He's somewhere in his,
I'll say 61 in Casey's listed and I
know he's like 63, but he still lifts,
still wears like a wife beater.
But he's a classic guy, you know,
he is still, he can still fuck
somebody up. That's, you know,
it's very inspirational.
He was funny about him too,
is that you can tell that he a,
we were talking about having a
temper and a, I have a temper,
but I wear my more on my sleeve,
which lets you know that I'm pretty much
harmless, but it's, it's the guys who,
you know, have a temper and they're,
they're, they're really soft spoken.
Those are the guys who will literally
twist your fucking head off like a fucking
beer cap. You know, those
guys, he's one of those dudes,
like somebody told me you're fucking
story about him doing some crazy shit.
And then I asked him about it and then
he's telling the story and he's just, Oh,
you know, and I can't, you know, you
had a situation and uh, you know,
it things got interesting and uh,
you know,
I mean it's just one of those
things is what happened.
And they just like immediately moves on
and then later on you find out he beat
the shit out of seven guys with like a
fire hydrant,
you know,
as opposed to the other guy who doesn't
even throw a fucking punch and then adds
like 97 details.
Right.
So I could tell the way he was
standing that he was a south pass,
so I start cheating to the right. Right.
Shut the fuck up dude. I'm telling you,
I'm taking this Jujitsu stuff. You know,
I started watching spike, you know,
without I gotta I gotta Ghee.
I went down there,
I took one class that got my ass kicked,
but uh,
I'm really good at like seeing things
for like an hour and then being able to
talk about them.
Like,
I've been doing it for 10 years while
my nose just had another level of being
fucking stuffed up. Ah, okay.
This is going to be a short
podcast everybody. Um, all right.
What else can I admit to that's fucking
embarrassing. Sat, embarrassing.
A Santa Claus is coming to town.
Is that the name of it is on tomorrow.
That that claymation thing that I used
to watch as a kid and I'm recording it
and I'm going to watch
it with my girlfriend.
Hopefully I'll have a Christmas
tree up by then and uh,
if I had a fireplace that we get
a fire going, but I doubt so uh,
I'll just late our little
fuck candle. Um, anyways,
happy holidays to everyone.
I have not even started
my shopping. Um, you know,
I do a thing on this podcast
where people give me an a,
I give people advice and this
week somebody is actually
giving me advice how to
fuck to both nostrils get
clogged up at the same time.
They fuckin dog sleeps all day,
all day long and then it comes in at
night and is like tired from sleeping.
You're a bum. Look at you. You know,
I'm teaching the dog how to speak
in them, but I swear to God, I give,
you got to hear it. You got to hear
it. It's absolutely adorable to me.
It will be annoying to you. And I'm
gonna. I'm gonna fucking play it. Oh,
I know what I wanted to do.
I wanted to go on fucking youtube and
find out why Carsello got suspended
against the fucking
capitals. Dude. That guy,
I swear to God is like Mickey
Featherstone on fucking skates.
Jimmy [inaudible]. You know,
that's why when I look at it,
he's got that same haircut. Anybody
read that book? The westies.
That's what he reminds me of.
Like you should be in Hell's
kitchen to the seventies.
But he's played for the
flyers. All right. Cars Sylo
suspended. Let's see what this
brings up. Sorry. Winston Churchill,
a cheap shot cars. Sylo uh, that's
2000. What the fuck did he do?
But anybody knows what he did. Let me
know. Just let me know what he did.
He did something against the
capitals. I have no fucking idea. Uh,
anyways,
let's get onto the advice.
Somebody wanted to give me some advice
this week, which is a nice turn of the,
if I consider we get it as
the holidays. Um, all right.
Jesus Christ Carsello has more fight
videos that Brittany Spears has look at my
vagina videos. Thank you.
That was a joke. Sorry,
I'm sick. This is really bad. Come
on bill. Step it up. Oh, you know,
I didn't finish telling her this
story about the guy downstairs, right?
So this fucking asshole, this
is what he does. Anytime,
uh, my girlfriend walks across the
floor, he just goes, why does he say,
he goes like, oh great,
keep it up. Keep it up.
He says he's real sarcastic and it
infuriates my girl to no fucking dead.
To the point that she's claiming that
he's harassing her and she wants me to go
downstairs and have a talk with this guy.
There's no way this isn't
going to be fucking hilarious,
which I'm going to go do. Right. But
I don't understand. Like if this guy,
what did this guy just says? You
know, why don't you go fuck yourself?
What am I going to do? I mean, I wouldn't
fight this guy. If he was my age,
I would now I would have a fucking seven
year old guy who lives alone at all.
It's the same fucking thing. I'm just
like, why don't you just laugh it off?
I dropped something. What? I was up here
one time and he goes, he's real sarcastic.
And he goes, do it again.
And you know what I did?
I did it again even harder and
I yelled out. How was that?
And he's never yelled at me again.
You know, you guys fucking harmless.
Jesus Christ having a word
in your life that what I got.
I got to run downstairs and confront this
guy like I'm at a Bronx Tale, you know?
Anyways. All right, here's the advice. I
got. Jesus Christ by fucking knows this.
It's done fully 19 minutes.
So this is going to be a half
hour one. All right guys,
I'm sorry. Whatever you got shopping to
do. Don't ya? Can I shop for Kwanzaa?
Hanukkah? Uh, are there, how many days?
A hundred car? There's, I like 13.
Why don't I keep asking questions
about the Jewish religion?
I think I'm searching for something new.
You know,
I'm a [inaudible]
aware of my mortality.
Um,
especially with the swine flu
that I caught out in Cleveland.
Don't you guys just celebrated or one
day or do you really have to buy somebody
13 fuck gifts and give
them some every day?
That's it. More that a
religious bullshit. That's,
that's their version of Jesus Pollard
the fish out of the fucking basket where
it's some Guy Dave Jebidiah.
He only had enough fucking knock Zima
to keep the zits off his face for five
days and sub, but somehow he
did it for fucking 13 rarely.
Who gives a shit just set
around the collection basket.
We'll keep paying for your bed sheets.
All right,
dear bill, irregular serve
you weekly podcasts, uh,
which I enjoy immensely.
Thank you.
I noticed that on occasion that you
have met should you are learning to play
guitar. First of all, Kudos. Secondly,
please tell me that you will never
fucking incorporate any form of guitar
playing into your act.
I know it's easy to learn a few open
chords or they'd pile all your c grade
material. Just a bullshit
SOG. Although you could do it.
I know people read idiots would
laugh at you and you'd kill five,
10 minutes of set time, easy. However,
please promise me you will never stoop
to that level. Sincerely concerned.
Fat Ass. Fucking hilarious. Yeah, dude,
I have no intentions of doing that,
but I hope I do do it someday.
I'm standing up right now.
Hopefully this will clear me up. Uh
Oh. It's like magic. You're like that.
Like hear me sniffle or
this fucking thing. Um,
I actually hope that I do that one
day, sir. And you know why that is?
Because that would mean that I have
actually reached such a level of success
that no one around me can tell me what
a horrible mistake I'm fucking making
with my career. You know, kind of like
Al Pachino in the 90s. He was like, so,
you know,
such a legend at that point that one
director ever pulled him aside and was
like, Al, ah, you're yelling.
Yeah, yeah. You're, you're just,
you just sort of yelling here,
not you don't act and you're just
yelling. No, no, no, I'm serious.
We were like on the sixth day of the
shoot here and uh, you know what I mean?
The scene is like, you know, two lines.
You're get some coffee
and a donut and I'm,
yeah,
you just kind of yell at,
Oh, and I don't want to, I mean, I respect
you where the Godfather, but you know,
you just fuck, you know,
one of those deals.
So if I actually got to the point
where nobody actually told me to stop,
you know, to not go on stage
with a guitar, do it. I'm like,
I'm never gonna do that shit.
I should never say never.
But I'll tell you this, I,
I'd be lying if I didn't already fantasize
about doing it, you know, like fuck,
and having the greatest hour special
of all time. And then the end,
my encore is I come out, I play better
than Stevie Ray Vaughn, you know,
and then next thing you know, I'm
playing drums in them, crooked vultures.
When David Grohl asked to
take a night off, right?
Once you guys have fantasies like that,
you've got to dream big and let's sit
down and watch that. Courtney Cox fucking,
whenever the COO fucking cougar show is,
oh,
he had a little epilogue
here to this. He said, ps,
I saw that picture of you playing
with the victor Wooten band,
playing drums with them and know that
you've been an avid drummer for a long
time. So what's it like to
learn a real instrument now,
boo Yah,
that that's fucking guitarists are also
full of themselves with their feathered
hair playing the same fucking power cords
that have been playing since fucking
Peter Frampton. Once you guys get over
yourself, you know, you know what?
I hope you go to a holiday party and
for no particular reason, just in, in,
in this, in this, in the,
in the vein of a Bronx tale,
every time I think I'm
a Bronx tale is Chazz.
Palminteri in the end of that pistol
just comes out and whacks him in the back
of the head. You know I helped that APP
is to you, but it's a fucking Ukulele.
I don't want you to die,
but I just really want you to take a
nice fucking get a little blunt force
trauma with the Ukulele. What
do you think about that? Huh?
I would love to have
youtube video of you alone.
You know some of this stupid rock
poses that you probably did back in the
eighties if you're older. Huh? Did
you do the point in a little kick?
We did.
You do the thing,
the state trooper to the 10th power
where you stand with your legs apart but
really far apart. Huh? Admitted
you ever done that? Mr Guitarist?
Mister fucking musician.
Ah, he never would do it.
A little tap on solo in the bathroom
mirror and then started flicking your
tongue like you were looking at Colette.
Ah,
cause you saw the white snake video.
Did you lick your guitar?
Like the Douche bag in that band?
That's what I want to know. The fucking,
you know, guitars are so fucking
annoying. I really think, you know,
they all think they're fucking
virtuosos. They're not, you know,
they're doing the same bullshit. I
actually didn't notice that, you know,
I'm not even going to say that.
Why would I do that?
Then it'd be shitting on a band
that I fucking like. All right,
let's plow ahead here. The fuck is
wrong with my keyboard here. Um,
all right, Bill. Oh, this is, this
is what I would tell you right now.
This guy's asking me for
advice and I don't know.
I don't know what to do on this one.
Okay. So I need some help on this one.
All right, Bill, I have
a situation for you.
Um, so I've been banging this engage
girl for the past several months
and we're in, we just went in with
both feet. Okay. How's the water? Fine.
All right.
I started with the two years ago where
we took a break for a year when she got
in in 2008.
Um,
she reinitiated our
arrangement over the summer.
Uh,
what the fuck? Sorry guys. I got to
stand up here. So I'm looking fucking,
all right. While I know it's wrong
to be bagging and engaged girls.
She's a petite Latin girl,
a great lay a,
she's 22 and a fiance lives over
in London. A guy yesterday too.
That's what he says. Yeah, you
just justified it. However,
now that the miserable son of a bitches
moving from London to New York to be
with her,
it hit me that marriage is actually a
serious move in life and this poor bass is
going to be spending the
rest of his life with her.
That only do I feel a bit guilty though.
I don't hesitate to call her at 4:00
AM when I'm at least 20 drinks deep.
I feel bad for the poor guy that
he's going to be marrying this slag.
Maybe this girl is so fucking whore is
she actually compares the size of my deck
with her fiance's. Wow. Uh, I mean,
she thinks that I'm going to be taken
as a compliment that mine is bigger and
she even invited me to her wedding.
What the fuck is wrong with her?
Jesus Christ, dude, it is
a situation. Uh, he said,
I'm going to use a,
I'm going to use her as exhibit a when
I educate my son's on how women are
complete whores. Really? So now they're
all whores because of this one here. Dude,
you really, you, you picked
a fucking winner here. Uh,
in any event,
my question boils down to this.
My friend suggest that I write
her fiance and anonymous email.
Um, I was thinking more of one of those
kidnapping letters with the different
letters cut out from magazines did
that would be fucking hilarious.
Um, about how I was, uh,
whatever the letter would be about how
I was begging her for the last several
months. What do you
think? While I hate rats,
I think I'd be saving this guy in
lifetime of misery. On the other hand,
that bastard propose to her after
only three months of meeting her.
So he kind of deserves it.
Am I doing this poor bastard or favor?
Any advice would be appreciated. Ah, okay.
Okay. Okay. Okay. Where do we go
with this one? What should you do?
MMM.
[inaudible]
well, you know what,
dude, in a perfect world,
you could actually send a letter to that
guy. You could tell him what was up.
And once he got over the shock of it, he
would actually be like, oh, thank God.
You know, you know, I'm not saying
he would like you, but he'd be like,
thank God you did me a favor.
I almost fucking married this psycho.
Right?
And, and then the little Latino
hoary girl would be like, you know,
as mad as I am at you, um, you were right.
I was doing the wrong fucking thing.
So I should probably shouldn't be getting
married to a mature blah, blah, blah,
blah, blah. And uh, and
then you'd stop fucking her.
Yeah,
right.
That would be the perfect world.
But this is probably what's going
to happen. You're going to do it.
This guy's going to flip out and flip out,
has a whole rainbow of emotions
anywhere from collapsing in the street,
crying and peeing on himself to going
over there and choking that woman to
death.
Um,
and she's going to flip the fuck out at
you and it's just gonna be a big fucking
mess.
Okay?
You go with your gut here.
What kind of a fucking asshole?
What kind of a fucking asshole,
you know,
date somebody who lives on the
other side of the fucking ocean.
If you need a passport to get to the
person that you're going to marry you,
not only should you not marry them, you're
not even in a relationship with them.
You know what I mean?
Fuck that. That's fucking
retarded. You know what that is?
He was so used to fuck it.
All those pasty bitches over there in
London with their awful fucking teeth and
their fish and chips breath.
All of a sudden he comes over in New York
on the fucking Puerto Rican Pride Day
parade and it was over. That's what
happened. That's what I'm guessing.
Okay.
Couple of those little j Lo girls came
walking by and he said, Holy Shit,
life doesn't have to be this hard.
It's just like sexy beast,
you know?
Do you ever meet the a Miss London? I
remember that guy was fucking say it all.
It's shit
Evie Cantwell along face Dell.
Make me laugh.
He really made the London seem miserable.
I'm just fucking with you guys. Some
reason I keep shitting on England here.
Yeah Dude. You know what? You got a
great story. Just fucking tap out mad.
You don't want to do that shit. You
know, lets his story. Just tell it a bar.
Fuck this guy.
Fuck up.
You know,
come on.
Rarely this girl is this pick up.
I don't know.
But women are so great at fucking lie.
They really are better at than us.
They lie just as much as we do.
So I don't want to make this seem
like I'm trashing women here.
I view women that they're,
they're sitting in the same mud puddle
that were sitting in their animals just
like us with the same fucking desires.
The one thing I do like about this story
is what I've been saying all along,
getting into horrific arguments with
my girlfriend is, you know, they,
why don't they ever catch women cheating?
Yeah.
You know, tiger woods,
another guy getting busted.
It's like the sixth fucking
famous guy to get busted,
you know?
So it really,
people are starting to buy into this shit
that guys are the only ones who cheat.
And I can tell you this
being a road comic,
the amount of fucking married
women who have approached me,
I was face fucking ridiculous. You
really sit there. You got your job.
Oh my God. Did the fucking guy just yell
at me? I think he just yelled at me.
I fucking, what's he going to do? Huh?
By the time he walked up all my
stairs, you know what I'm saying? Um,
anyways, the fuck was I
just talking about. Yeah.
They just did just, they're fucking,
they're better at it. They're better.
They already like do a mild
form of lying all day long.
They call it manipulation, you
know, let's shut that. They do,
you know, they, they want something
and they just immediately,
they always know like, what
emotion? Let me try cute.
And they put their shoulders at,
he did a little fucking smile.
Or they do the pouty face,
you know?
Or do they act like they're just like
this helpless little fucking thing.
Those are all lies.
It's just all shit tickets.
That just basically means
there's something that I
don't want to do and I want
you to do it for me and I want you
to pay for it and I want you to,
and not only do I want you to do, like,
they're so good at it that it's not even,
it's not even good enough for
you to just do it for them.
They want you to actually enjoy it,
enjoy doing it for them like that.
Like that's how much they get
your fucking head spinning.
So that's why they never get
caught. That's my, that's
my belief. All right, Bill.
Uh, you know, if that made sense.
I sort of fucking zoned out halfway
through that with the Nyquil haze I have
going on here. No, actually took dayquil
deny. I don't fucking know. Anyways,
let's go to overrate.
Underrated. Overrated.
Condescending comes from Connecticut.
Jesus, a little, little literation.
They're condescending.
Cons from Connecticut who infest New
York bars and grade you on that three
dimensional grid of where you work.
Went to school and live these cuts,
work in PR,
make 30 grand a year and live off
daddy's AMX and his rent checks for their
Chelsea flats, uh, should be purged.
That didn't even make sense, dude. I don't
know if you edited that last sentence.
All right. Um, do you got, you
got some issues with women here.
Okay. First of all, you're going to wear,
there's condescending [inaudible]
there's plenty of great women out there.
You know, he just, you're, you're fishing
in the same poisoned pond. You know.
What are the names of these
places that you go to?
I lived in New York for 12 years. I never
met women like that. I never met him.
I ain't one of those a Wall Street bars,
you know,
go to work. What are some,
a little bit different?
Start off with like a sports bar that,
you know,
what about those wine bars?
Is that where you're going?
People sit there and a chat? I don't
know what the fuck I'm talking about.
Um, I'm just trying to take the edge off
of how bad women are getting trashed on
this, uh, underrated. Um,
what the fuck does that say?
Heleo sequence a kickass
band from Portland, Oregon.
H e l I. L sequence. All right, I'll check
those guys out. Thank you for the email.
All right,
let's to the questions and I'm going to
have to tap out guys because obviously I
feel too fucking hot here. All right,
questions bill. Um, love the podcast,
but,
but all,
here's what it from a guy who actually
went to my Saturday night show at
hilarity. He's in Cleveland. Um, as
such, I was at your late show for, uh,
last Friday night,
a Saturday night in Cleveland.
The group I was with went out for dinner
or drinks before the show and everyone
was having a great time.
So we get to the club,
take our seats to the waitress and forms
by buddy that they have some absence
Martinis have set,
I believe was illegal for a long
time and recently now it isn't.
They used to think of, make
people go crazy or something
like that. Um, so anyways,
so he offers to buy them.
Uh,
so I buddy offers to buy those absent
Martinis for everyone in our group.
Mind you,
um,
everyone had said that they were not
planning on drinking at the club due to
various obligations they had the next day.
So he buys was for everyone but me,
I'm driving even though no one
really seems to want it. Dot.
My girlfriend is a small girl as such,
cannot really hold their liquor that well.
So this Martini cubs that she didn't
want and she begins to drink it.
I see you're sipping on it throughout
the opening of middle acts until it's
finished. Finally, you get onstage.
We're all laughing our asses off.
That'll all of a sudden I noticed her
stop. I look at her ask if she's okay,
to which she shakes her head and says no.
And she says,
she needs me to take her to the bathroom.
Why?
I need to go. I have no idea. You know
why? Because she's a fucking woman.
They drag you down with them.
If you had to fucking Puke,
you would just get up and puke.
Right? I need you to go with me.
Okay.
Fucking, Oh God, it's so fucking annoying.
Why I need to go. I have no idea.
I guess so I get, uh, I have no idea.
I guess so I get to look like,
I guess so I get to look like the Douche
walking out with their behind me anyway,
she ends up puking and I ended up having
to take her home missing half of your
show.
So my question is,
should I be mad at my buddy for buying
her the extremely potent drink that she
didn't want or should I be pissed at her
for drinking it after saying she didn't
want it because she didn't want to get
drunk. I'm kind of mad at both of them,
but more so at her because no one put a
gun to her head and forced her to drink.
She chose to. Um, all right.
Who should you be mad at?
Um,
MMM Christ.
I don't, I don't fuck it.
These are hard questions.
Yeah.
Do you know what? You should kind of
be mad at yourself for some hot item.
First of all, you know, I need
you to go with me to the bathroom.
You know, that's just
one of, you know what,
that's one of those things where you
shouldn't have to go to the fucking
bathroom, but that's one of
those things, if you don't,
they're going to make it seem like,
you know,
it's Vietnam and you took off in the
chopper and left him down there like
fucking Willem to fall. You know what
I mean? It just becomes that. Yeah,
if you think I would have fucking
blah, blah, blah, you know,
it's amazing sweetheart.
Why you're always a hero in
these hypothetical situations.
You know why that is?
Because they're hypothetical
and annoys me.
Why do you have to go to the
fucking bathroom? What did you do?
You can't go in there.
What she did?
You sit there with like a glass up to the
door so you get to hear her puking. Um,
who should you be mad at?
A,
you should break your fucking buddies
balls and then tell your girl that she
needs to take you out for a
fucking something or other.
Just go and make her do something for you.
Break a break or fucking balls about it,
you know?
Cause you've got fucked in all of that.
You brought your buddies a dickhead.
What do, what do you care? You know,
he's probably trying to bang the
other girl that's at the table, right?
He's doing what he's doing.
He's getting everybody look it up.
He's trying to be a show
off, right? Yeah, absolutely.
I used to be illegal writing. What is
all the fucking things? I don't know.
That's what,
that's what I would do.
I break your buddy's balls and
that I'd make your girlfriend,
I don't know.
Totally go make your breakfast
or something. It's sad.
Is chauvinistically as possible,
you know? And if she doesn't,
I would just start jerking off right
in front of her. But that's mate.
That's what I do. All right,
next question. Hey Bill,
a big fan of yours from the opiate Anthony
show and the Monday morning podcast.
You do look to the, to the,
to the quick question for you.
I am a military vet. I'll do this is
a brutal, this is a brutal situation,
situation. Um, all right,
quick question for you. I am a military
veteran and I also happened to be Korean.
Um, I'm in college right now
and all my friends are white.
When we hang out and get drunk,
the ugly racist shit comes out.
I know the difference between
joking around in real hate.
My problem is I was homeless week
getting food with my dad went outside.
I hear, fuck you chink, yelled at us.
I went blind with rage and jumped out
of the car that was going about 20 miles
an hour. I chased those, fuck the two
fucks down, but they will, I try to,
but they were too fast and got away.
I'm chink is probably the
racial slur that hurts the most.
That shit really eats away at me
and my parents are immigrants,
but they work hard and I've never fucked
over anyone or cheated on their taxes,
etc. I felt that I served my country for
a year in the desert just to come back
and still be hated because I have a small,
because I have small eyes and
a tiny penis or you just, wow.
Okay. Okay. Um,
any advice on how to
handle undeserved racism?
Uh, many advice to help
my friends understand what
it's like to be a minority.
Anyways, let me know what you
think. A huge fan of fucking chink.
I'm all right, dude. All right.
The first advice I would give you is
when you want somebody to understand what
it feels like to be a minority,
you probably shouldn't ask
a white male heterosexual.
Because I read that whole
thing and my big question was,
what is when you're hanging out with
your friends and they get drunk and you
know all the racist stuff out,
and you were like,
I can tell the difference
between joking and just, uh,
in real hate. Uh, my question is, is why?
Just because you're Korean that it just
seems like my brain for half a second
was like, oh, he's Korean. So because
he is a minority in this country,
that means he's incapable of
racist thoughts. My question
would be, I'll, I'll ask,
I've got a question for you.
Have you ever thought something fucked up?
You had to have,
you know,
you never saw a black guy
coming down the street like, oh,
this guy's going to rob me. And
then it turned out, uh, you know,
he just cured pancreatic cancer or some
shit. You know, that never happened.
Who doesn't have that fucking story?
Right. It doesn't make you a bad person,
but what are you supposed to do?
Come of age when gangster
rap is on the television.
You live in the white suburbs.
You don't know any better. Um,
the fuck am I doing here? Let me
try to answer this question. Well,
what the fuck was the question?
Um,
any advice on how to
handle undeserved racism?
Oh Jeez. I mean, I dunno. I Dunno
what intuit, in a perfect world,
you could go out there and beat the
living shit out of him and everyone else
would cheer you on as you did it,
you know,
and then buy a drink for serving the
country. I mean, that's, you know,
the world I would like to live
in. You know, you wouldn't
kill those people. Well,
I guess you would cause they're
not gonna change. Yeah. Fuck it.
Okay.
You know, then I'll have to
traffic a little bit. Um,
I don't know what to tell you,
dude. Well, why don't you, um,
I'm not trying to be an asshole here,
but I would,
I would probably not hang out with people
who got drunk and suddenly started to
sound racist. You know, I would pick
a better group of friends. I mean,
it's bad enough.
You got to hear it from strangers.
I wouldn't want my inner circle
of people like, you know,
that's not a good thing. That's not a
good sign. Do you know, when I get drunk,
I like to explain stuff. I don't just
start, you know, putting on a Klan Hood.
So that would be my advice. I would
get some better friends. And, um,
as far as helping your
friends to understand what
it's like to be a minority,
I just, they're not going to
be able to understand it. Yeah.
It's, they're just not,
they would have to, uh,
move to South Africa and to have a farm
that was being taken away from him or
some shit, uh, they'd have to do it
like that. You know, I don't know.
And even then they would
still have the arrogance of a,
I am a fucking from the white race. They'd
still have that card to throw it down,
you know? But it really got ugly, you
know? So, uh, I don't think, yeah,
I don't think somebody white could
ever understand that. You know,
you can empathize,
you can listen to the stories and nod
and have a concerned look on your face.
But at the end of the day, you know, I
don't know. Well, let me ask you this,
like a Koreans. All right. Now as far as
I know about Asia, Japanese are sort of,
the white people have a,
of Asia, you know, well,
they kind of don't take,
kind of consider themselves superior or
they look down on the Chinese and the
Koreans and that type of shit.
And they've kind of been just a little
country with their little shogun warrior
practices.
Is that what they tried to do?
The rape and Dan King and all that shit
that they did in World War Two? You know,
how to Koreans feel, why am I asking
you this? Man? You're from America.
Have you ever robbed me? I haven't read
any books on Ireland or Germany. Yeah,
I'm an asshole. Yeah. I wouldn't even
fly by you even listening to this. Um,
anyways. You know what I would
do? Said Steve Bird in email,
comedian Steve Byrne, hilarious
comedian. And he is, uh, he's half white,
half Korean?
I believe so.
Um,
yeah.
He'd probably tell you to punch
him in the face if I know him.
He likes to play hockey. All right.
More overrated. Underrated. Uh,
I had a great time, but you
show in Cleveland. Did it,
it today underrate. Okay. Um,
your, um, okay,
there's this eat this guy
basically did an overrated,
underrated from the
show that he saw me do.
He said underrated the
way nonsmokers smell.
MMM.
I'm not saying that your fans steak,
but sweet Jesus Christ.
I kept looking around during your set
because I could've sworn that someone was
smoking a cigarette, especially
those two Hicks who are heckling you.
I was behind the midline for your DVD or
they just reeked of cheap tobacco would
booze. I'm not some militant anti
smoking guy. As a matter of fact,
I quit smoking about four months ago.
I'm just horrified that I smelled that
bad for 20 years and wasn't even aware of
it.
The other underrated people who don't
have to tell you every thought that pops
into their head,
the guy sitting behind me at your show
is easily the guy who was laughing the
loudest, which I'm guessing is
good for you as a comedian. Uh,
what you couldn't hear,
thankfully his,
the way he would comment on almost
everything you said on stage.
MMM.
Now he goes to give some examples. Uh,
what a great analogy bill just made.
That is really, that is a really
old reference. That's hilarious.
I can't believe bill just said that.
Jesus,
how did you not punch
that guy in the throat?
And he said he did about a
thousand more deep observations.
Obviously he's being sarcastic.
Uh,
I was glad it was enjoyed
your show so much, but fuck,
I just want it to turn around and tell
him it's okay to just think these things
that you should have said
that, uh, you don't think, uh,
you don't have to tell your buddy every
reaction you're having to build, choke,
save something for the ride
home for Christ's sake.
But I didn't say anything because of a
peace loving pussy who just sits there
and lets people know him.
Thanks for the great show and was nice
to meet you afterwards. All right dude.
Sorry you had that bad time.
Yeah, that was a weird show.
I just had a couple of couple of drugs
there who thought they were helping the
show and uh,
they weren't.
So I fucked with him a couple of times
and then I just had to deliberately make
it uncomfortable.
And then I got out of it.
And then what ended up happening was
most people didn't even hear him.
So they were like, what did
they say? What did they say?
They were yelling Jew and then
they kept yelling, faggot.
That's what they were doing.
I don't know why I made a reference to
a Drayton and then they thought it would
be funny if they just kept yelling Jews.
I don't know why they were vibing on,
on some shit.
And then I was talking about some sort
of homophobic thing and then they were
yelling, you faggot, you fucking faggot.
Faggot. The whole, the entire joke,
like every two and a half seconds.
Uh,
and in their world it was hilarious
and it was helping my set.
So where are you going
to do all right? I, uh,
I'm going to go take a bath
is a visual for you.
I'm all fucking aches and pains here
and I'm not gonna fucking take a shower
like a fucking man. Uh, that's it. That's
some money money podcast this week.
I apologize for the,
uh,
the nasal problems here and,
I apologize to my country
downstairs neighbor.
Everybody have a great week and a
police come out and see me up at a,
the punchline up in Sacramento,
um,
uninformed radio.com to listen to my
radio show with the wonderful Joe Derosa,
the teen idol,
a teen idol sensation of the opiate
Anthony Radio Program on Sirius Xm.
What else can I hype?
I think that's it.
Got a billboard.com I have about five
people on my mailing list away from having
10,000 people on my mailing list,
and I would like as a Christmas gift
for four of you to sign up for it.
Could you do that? Lovely. And that's it.
You guys have a great week and I'll talk
DMX
[inaudible]
[inaudible].